so i think this is a really
a really important one because most
professionals have skills of some
variety
you've got to break them apart and
understand them and how you can
make them applicable to where you want
to go so let's take a couple examples
the first is if you are a functional
executive so you know
about human resources you know the legal
department you know communications you
know finance you know marketing if you
think about it very even sales a lot of
what organizations have to do are
functional skills
those are very very transferable and in
fact the fact that you're coming from a
different industry may make you more
desirable because you can bring lessons
from one industry to another that can be
really helpful so if you're in a
functional area you are probably the
most
uh
well positioned to make a career easy to
transfer those things but they're things
you might not have thought about that
are also
really transferable skills if you have
been in startups and you've helped scale
a company from you know two employees to
20 to 100 to a thousand that's a very
replicable skill right and that's useful
to a lot of people even industry you
know you're in you and i were both in
entertainment
if we wanted to pivot to technology
which is now a
very exciting place to be
how do you use your entertainment
experience well you've got a lot of
technology companies that need to
partner or sell to entertainment
companies you are very valuable to them
so you can use that industry knowledge
to transfer to a different industry
the one great example of that is
government um if you look around in
government you'll see cabinet
secretaries who have been you know
secretary of um treasury and then
secretary of state or
head of the office of management and
budget and then secretary of defense i
mean the government actually has done a
really good job maybe better than the
private sector of recognizing that
there's a core set of skills that if a
manager has that can be
put into
at the highest levels of you know
importance in the world can be
transferred
so it's something to think about and to
look at your skill set and see
the gold nuggets in it right and pull
them out and be able to imagine how you
could apply them in a new a new venue
this actually reminds me of someone that
i think you're gonna know who i'm
talking about that works with our
company yes who is uh she's just a
career manager and she she'd had many
many many years of career of you know
high power jobs and fortune 100
companies but if you looked at what that
skill was it was so transferable she can
just manage her way through anything
right and the fact that she'd been in
and then she came you know to business
talent group but the fact that she'd
been in all these different industries
i think gives her perspective that much
more you know
some value and the thing that's really
interesting about her is she took a
number of years off i think six or seven
so a significant amount of time to
pursue some personal objectives
when i looked at her what was clear to
me is the skills she had didn't go away
right she didn't forget how to manage
you don't lose that muscle
and that's an important thing to
remember too that you know just because
you knew a skill and you haven't done it
for a while it's like riding a bike you
don't lose it and so don't be afraid
right and don't diminish your knowledge
because you may have taken a path that
you know took you on a different place
for a couple years
these are core skills
and you should be able to leverage them
and use them in your new direction